[Music]
yeah we've started to get some hate
lately when we started Jubilee media two
years ago it was maybe 350 K subscribers
now that we're about to hit four million
I think it's only recently we've
realized how powerful our platform has
become we've dropped the ball a few
times but we also want to be as honest
and transparent with you guys as
possible show some new Jubilee faces
address some issues so enjoy the episode
and see you guys on the other side we
make like three videos a week so over
the course of a year it's like a hundred
and fifty to two hundred videos so
obviously we're not gonna make every
single video like to the standard that
you know we have for ourselves so we
should we should it's just more likely
than not we're not gonna hit it out of
the park every time we just try to go
even harder the next time I just know
there are videos that I feel like don't
represent those communities well or
represent the issues well we may be cave
to just like it's better than nothing
but we are trying to help represent a
community and an issue and we should
always hold ourselves up to a bar even
if that means that making quota
there's probably what five to ten
percent of the videos that we actually
create finish spend all this money time
on and we don't put out that's also like
part of the process that a lot of folks
don't see and I'm pretty proud that we
do still keep the bar pretty high what I
really want to double down on for our
team is like we're 15 people but we
literally effect like millions of people
like people look to us to be the ones
who like represent these people well so
we just have to realize like the account
of
we have I think we do yeah I do I'm like
no I feel the 3.6 million subscribers
that we have like on my back as I go to
sleep at night I think if this prompt
was like is there a video on our channel
that I don't like yeah absolutely I
think I've learned from the first video
I put out that there's like someone out
there who's relating to it who's
disliking it and loving it or whatever
and so it's my job to like make
something that can touch people in the
right ways I originally went to somewhat
disagree because if we really were to
going with everything our audience
dictated like the gun of use I don't
think we would be making as much LGBT
content as we do I know I want to make a
thing about Polynesians but I know in my
head I'm like ah but with the audience
show up with the views be too low and I
see that actually affecting the choices
I make I think our channel can be so
much more colorful with like the kind of
content that we're creating
I think we're slowly getting there and
like doing and going out there and doing
different things I don't think I'm fit
to direct like a spectrum Latino you
know what I mean
like do a Latinos think the same I feel
like I'd rather be working on something
else that relates to like my history or
my experience but are we always gonna be
underprepared to like address lots of
topics I don't know that we should not
do a topic because you're not Latino
right that that you feel like maybe you
could be a little bit more prepared
because you don't have all that
background and experience but if we sort
of did everything that way there's
probably a lot that we probably you know
wouldn't be able to touch maybe it's
like the the business hat I don't know
what it is but I feel like all these
people who are entrusting us who want to
see content from us our entire job is to
figure out how we take the mission we
have and serve it in a way to them that
they care about I don't think that means
they get to like guide our company but I
do think that they should be top of mind
and who we're serving it's getting hot
in here
metaphorically and literally if you walk
you get a little air I didn't register
the prompt fully sorry it's not like
anything like tension or anything and
you're gonna edit it to make it seem
like I think about it
but I wasn't thinking about it it's our
job okay yeah I think it's our
responsibility to do all that we can to
protect them and whatever that means on
a case-to-case basis but can we always
protect them no because I mean we put
them on the internet and millions of
people watch it and we don't necessarily
we can't protect them from everything I
can't control what you have on your
Instagram or what you said on set I will
make sure it's as accurately portrayed
as possible I've had a lot of cast
members who asked me before going on the
show like I'm just worried about you
make like looking bad in the Edit we'll
put it this way it's on you to conduct
yourself in the most mature thoughtful
manner possible and I will honor that
but if you come acting in a search in a
way I'm not gonna try to fix that for
you a lot of times we're actually erring
on the side of trying to make people
look better because we do fear for them
right like we do want to protect them we
try really hard to make things feel
balanced and I think it's why our edits
are so difficult and takes so long the
comments though we don't really have
control over the comments which is
something we talk about often sometimes
our brood rule to us like you know what
I mean and that we tell our cast mates
not to read the comments but you don't
read the comments
[Music]
the reason I want people to comment and
like if they say they're the wrong bangs
and they attack people we talked about
like white supremacist and this and that
we don't know who those people are
unless we're opening up the floodgates
for them to comment and you know what I
mean and so that we can know their name
we know an account I don't know though
get to them because it's literally just
you're behind a computer screen there is
no accountability for the commenter but
I think if we shut them off like that's
ignoring the real problem I mean for us
that we might be able to look at those
comments and be like oh these people are
racist or these people have this problem
and we might be prepared to handle that
but like the casts that are in our
videos like they're normal people they
don't work in media they're like why are
all these people like saying I should
die do you know any means I feel like
with that it's it's a tricky balance so
I agree actually with like keeping
people accountable but if people are
sending like personal addresses and
stuff and that would you do you feel
like no that's why I moved a little bit
honestly cuz like the personal and like
animation harm and like that's that's
different for me it's literally just
where someone's like safety is at play
or when there's just no insight it's
just pure attack what's an example
though of like an attack so YouTube has
something already like even without us
doing anything called like potentially
flagged comments if you go read them you
will know what I'm talking about it is
it is like I hate this mother after I'm
gonna like kill them like I hope think I
like like that's not a valuable comment
I'm sure the one that we're all thinking
about is Aaron from The Vegan episode
right because that's the one time we've
ever taken down comments anywhere and
that was on Instagram this was like a
big discussion within our team because
we all kind of disagreed about like
should we do that because we're against
censorship obviously we want people that
like be able to articulate their opinion
in a safe way
but in that particular scenario it
seemed like there was personal
information about her workplace or even
home that people were starting to share
that we said wow if this amounts like
physical
violence in some white were responsible
for that for the Instagram post we
turned off all comments yes I mean like
we shut down conversation do you think
we should have it would have taken a lot
more work but we could have gone and
sort of taken down things that were like
explicitly so that's why I think maybe
the audience felt a little bit more like
we don't even trust them you know nobody
can say anything well we didn't trust
them at that point they were yeah you
know like I feel like we had reason to
not trust and I mean there were plenty
of other places they could have had
dialogue I don't understand why we're
getting so much heat returning off
comments on one post we wanted to do
things the right way and we want to be
authentic to our audience frankly like
we disagree with the way that she
handled herself on set but she chose to
do that I mean I speak for I think the
way she was acting on set was fine I
mean it's a game that's what people
don't realize you know what I mean she
wasn't calling him names or anything she
was just saying he's not vegan which i
think is hilarious so but it's funny yes
I don't think that she was being like
disrespectful or like rude I think like
the way it was perceived absolutely just
because I've been in odd man out I think
like it is very competitive you're like
trying to find the person
[Music]
if you start to discriminate too much of
who comes on set or not and you just
start having all goody goody two-shoes
people on set who are very agreeable and
you don't have these sort of people you
don't have the conflict that causes the
interesting things that happen on a
practical level you can't predict what
people are gonna do when you put them in
like a situation like this that can be
kind of a pressure cooker people are
that have surprised me who have come off
very mellow and a phone call the second
you put them in an environment like
middle ground or spectrum or odd man out
a whole other side of them comes out
that even surprises them I also
recognize that there is value in taking
a risk with someone who might be a
little bit unpredictable but has
something really strong to say and is
passionate everybody I put in I believed
in that did some people not give me what
I was hoping sure but I hesitate with
the word of should I never have included
them in the first place like with that
idea looking in retrospect is how I how
I answer this question let's just take
middle ground for example the whole
point of middle ground is to show the
world how to have a conversation with
opposing sides so for me a person that
would be a poor choice to have in that
video is someone who's constantly
cutting people off not letting anyone
else talk just like yelling you know
like that's the extreme example the fact
that they show up yeah the two opposing
sides is like the start of the
conversation so I think that's also like
a great example of the fact that they
showed up I show up and I also think
that the way that we dialogue shouldn't
be controlled I think like sometimes we
get angry you know what I mean and like
a conversations look ugly but at the end
of the day someone's walking away more
informed than they did before and so I
don't want to like control the way
people like dialogue I don't know people
aren't seeing the air between those
moments of when we're taking breaks and
chatting with each other when we're
checking in with each other those aren't
in the edit
because we're not going to watch two
hours of people chillin as we redo the
lighting there have been times I've been
incredibly emotionally taxed like I've
pulled multiple all-nighters but I feel
like the more I've taken on the more
I've found ways to just be more
effective and take care of myself we're
in this space this digital space but
we're artists Merson I'm sensitive about
the work that I create and to see
outside yourself is exhausting it's
tiring but at the same time I love my
job I love being an artist and I
wouldn't change it for the world
I based my self-worth a lot off what I
do and so if a video doesn't do well or
it's not hitting the bar I expect of it
as far as the quality of the video and
maybe not always the views I look at
that as a reflection of my abilities
that I did the best I can and that
wasn't good enough and so that can be
difficult to deal with mentally the
hardest part is that I recognize for
myself my purpose is to serve our
community and serve people and I don't
always feel like I'm doing that well and
so that can be a little difficult to
swallow when I think I've missed the bar
and I'm letting this community down and
I'm letting people down I just want to
do right by our communities and our
people and help talk about our struggles
and what we're going through in the
world and I get frustrated when I don't
do that right and I expect myself to do
better and so I think like the directors
I totally understand how you guys are
standing over there in terms of like
your self-worth we look at you guys and
we're like you guys are doing like so
far like above and beyond like what we
could ever expect or like hope for so I
don't want you guys to be on strongly
agree forever
yeah just want you guys to know that we
see you guys the reason I stand here is
like I'm like I get emotional for me
it's not even about videos or about like
our performance it's really about people
and it's hard like when I see you guys
struggling and stay up late and my
killing ourselves making these videos
it's like I'm both incredibly proud but
I'm also it hurts me because I'm like oh
are we loving and honoring our directors
are we loving and honoring our team I
feel accountable for every one like we
need to pay fee ensure all these people
because our families that we want people
to grow and how do you balance those
things and how do we just get everyone
to the level where we're thriving it's
emotionally exhausting in some ways but
I also think it's like the greatest
honor that I have we're trying to build
something great and we're getting better
hey guys thank you so much for watching
that uh Paso spectrum it was a little
weird to direct that yeah I don't know
it's just like very meta if he was
really good for us honestly yeah it's
good to talk about it openly - yeah yeah
you know nothing hidden behind closed
doors I feel like I said some idiotic
things and I'm gonna regret later it's
okay be nice to Ian in the comments be
nice alright thank you guys we'll see
you next time bye